concrètement les pilotes de saturne je
vais vous plaisait c'est ce qui nous
défend son apparent ne défendons pas
payer mais d'abord chassés du gpmm abord
je ne sais pas personne j'exprime d'un
point de vue ensuite effectivement
deuxième élément moi j'ai une question
quand même à vous poser c'est si vous
avez à ce point peur que discothèque
soient des lieux de contamination est
bien très bien mais reste garde on sait
comment ce que disait je m'entends
regardons ce qu'il fait passer ailleurs
est ce qu'au texas aujourd'hui nous
avons une reprise de l'épidémie est-ce
qu'en espagne nous avons des clusters au
sein des 10 dès lors quoi vous
fondez-vous ils se font sur rien c'est
dit que les problèmes de fond si vous
voulez c'est que vous vivez sous une
dictature c'est jusqu'au bout sa
dictature et l'ail bâton la dictature de
la peur est celle là ah oui personne que
je vous en libérer je pense que c'est ça
le problème
je parle effectivement aujourd'hui vous
avez peur de vivre et aujourd'hui il est
content de vivre
vous ne pouvez plus être dans une
logique où sur voit la vie à moitié
c'est plus possible mais sans ses tgv
tombent et les yeux lévis kocic
complètement lâché lives et dvd sur
l'hypothèque
c'est comme si on demandait à quelqu'un
qui n'a pas le permis ce que vous en
pensez oui j'ai quitté cette histoire de
passe passe ta sanitaire charrette à
biguglia va être une espèce de java est
une espèce de disque est sur du long
terme j'ai l'impression je suis moi
c'est ça qui me fait flipper un charmant
après qu'est ce qui est des boîtes de
nuit moi j'ai surtout l'impression que
le gouvernement n'ait pas assez jeune
pour se pencher sur le sujet parce
qu'ils sont généralement du mal afin que
johnny hallyday
j'ai du jour qui a sondé la sambre tous
ces 14 sur la piste ils nous font pas
faute sur moi j'ai une science la prada
les lattois son nom mais s'il vous plaît
là comme on a des nouvelles il paraît
que ça rouvrirait le 1er juillet ce que
vous êtes content avec la wii déjà de
concentration ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
très bien quand même parce qu'il faut
oublier qu'on travaille il faut qu'on
travaille
une chose est certaine ça vous dérange
ou pas n'ont par contre pas travailler
on peut travailler tout par contre il
faut être conscient que ça va pas être
facile parce que pas tout le monde sera
forcément dax signé au début et pas tous
les jeunes voudront faire un test pcr
deux fois par semaine bien sûr quoique
on est jeudi qu'après y aura une
discussion d'aménagement des aides
peut-être si au ps on est pris en avril
et juillet sakura ça va être bon 1er
juillet c'est bon on va ouvrir les
boîtes de nuit il sollicite aussi
s'organiser ok c'est vrai que je suis
est de faire de 3,7
merci les féroé